hi everyone very sad news evan has been
sick last week and students take the
squeeze so he's not been able to do many
videos he will be posting Steve dropped
inspirational videos every day but we
have something fun to show you we have
been doing video replies to surprise
people who have commented on Evans
videos and here are some some of our
favorites hey Tamara just wanted to drop
a quick note to say thank you for all
the sharing and the support in the
comments go see clash of clans tips and
tricks we wanted to send you a shout out
because hayden love your your picture
because he has an angry face he's got an
angry face hey Gordon I just want to say
thank you for sharing my video I'm glad
you liked it I'm curious as to what city
that is in your your profile picture do
you know what that is I can't see I want
to know what city that is anyway very
nice that looks interesting I want to go
there maybe I've been there I don't
recognize it hey Steven greetings from
Toronto Canada best city to live in
Toronto oh the best city to live in the
world good yeah yeah I think actually it
is yeah The Economist the autonomous did
say it was the best of the live in the
world anyway the auto like thanks man
I've really appreciated thanks Lee I
really appreciate that you guys are the
ones that keep me going hey man thanks
for our love in the video thank you we
don't know the name of that song um but
sorry bro i'm going to make a terrible
pronunciation of your name let's go for
it nagaon needs a che I hope that's
close I'd love to actually know how to
pronounce that I'm curious this is
hayden and he really liked the flag that
was in your profile picture because it
colorful because it's colorful it's a
nice like I don't know what's like that
is
I don't know what's like that is but
it's colorful we like it our mark just
wanted to say thank you for the comments
recently we saw your comment on the
change your environment and the kevin
o'leary and wanted to give you a shout
out a thumbs up a double thumbs up the
quadruple thumbs up anyway what do you
know that's it one thing you want to
make a funny face to him or something
that's a pretty good funny face okay hi
jack hi jack hi jack is like yeah I jack
maybe that maybe I'll be the bus today
hey yeah hey Jack hey Jack best of luck
on your insurance career I'm excited to
see you do some amazing things hey Theo
is Evan annina we just wanted a thank
you for your for sharing my video on
kevin o'leary focus and dominate you
look pretty focused look at that picture
right we're looking at your pics right
now he looks pretty focused I would say
right focus and ready to dominate fila
style hey chefs TV congrats on going
full time in the business listen buddy
scheduling your time is important no
matter if you're doing it part time or
full time but good luck and just want
this in the book shadowed love all the
comments and support over the past
couple months are you like kissing what
are you doing there are you kissing shut
hey fern and thanks in that comment
really means a lot to me anyway Peyton
what are you doing what do you want to
say hey didn't saw your picture and he
thought what if you want to say what did
you like it it can I believe he likes
your profile picture because you guys
are cuddling yeah okay you want to say
bye bye hey hey hold on i'm making a
video here it's up j Thank You Man for
the the comment great job I appreciate
it I make these videos for you guys and
it's awesome notes have an impact listen
congrats on finding your passion hey man
thanks for watching welcome over to the
believe team thank you for subscribing
coming from Jonathan's post and Hayden
saw your picture
and you wanted to say yeah there you
look happy I agree what's up ed e ed ed
now ed edd Eddy anyway um listen I
honestly don't know enough about the
Australian market to give you guidance
on that but there is always a solution
man there is always a solution don't
don't rely on some crutch to say hey
this is how it's always been done it's
not gonna work in my market there's a
solution ok good luck getting that first
hire thank you for the comment have a
great night I guess Australia it's
morning right mine a bucket Knight
Fretwell Australia's oh yeah yes yeah
it's gonna be it's got it i don't know
if it's 12 hour 12 hours there anyway
hey Adam appreciate the support go out
there and spread the love that means a
lot to me your comment rock and hating
saw your picture and he thought he
thinks you're awesome I agree man have a
great day my wife's looking at me what
you're feeling it no okay um yeah I last
night I lost my flow there hey jarhead
hi thanks for commenting and like in the
radio show video we really appreciate it
hey hey J hey J hey hey Jay hi Jay oh
boy anyway just just a quick video
shout-out thanking you for your comment
hiring your first person is rough ah
you're touching my leg with all cheese
I'm getting distracted here and trying
to make a video okay um was I saying
hiring a person is uh oh yeah did we
start over the cut now just like it will
keep going now that will keep going it's
good yeah Ron Adam bro thank you for the
comment thank you for watching a radio
show for all 35 minutes I appreciate it
a lot of love goes into the radio show
and it's great to see the comments
coming in this is Nina what do you want
to say that to Adam thanks for the
support that's pretty good hey any
cat just wanted to look at URI got a big
smile on mr. why does this end a big
shout out to thank you for watching the
video and sharing it on your google plus
i really appreciate it poor a lot of
love into the videos and and it's great
to see that they're getting a reaction
and you like them anyway okay I like
your yellow shirt heizak sending a quick
shadow to you tonight thank you for the
comments glad you'd like to believe by
video and I guess thank you for saying
that it's not scary I guess that the
thumbnails a little bit scary it's like
oh yeah would you be scared with us yeah
yeah I'm with thee I don't know okay
well there you go it's a scary thumbnail
so thank you well thank you for letting
it be known not to be scared or he's
encouraging the people to watch uh you
know the League of Legends comment you
hurting me a little bit man you hurting
me i'm a fan named as a fan okay you're
okay I still love you man even though
you're hating on League and I'm a fan
still love you thank you for the
comments hey Todd what's up I'm loving
the orange shirt too I feel the brand
colors well that's your favorite color
yeah hey Bradley thank you for watching
a video really appreciate it and just be
you man just be you don't worry about
being too nice always be you and Hayden
here saw your picture and what did he
say yah he thinks you're awesome Valerie
so we wanted to make a quick video to
thank you for all the comments on all
the videos I showed Nina just now your
picture and said you left the comment
and she said I recognize the name and
the picture because you're leaving so
many comments and sharing so much love
so I'm glad you felt the the kanye video
I'm a big fan I love that video myself
and wanted to share with you guys so
thank you for the awesomeness and we
have anything else insane believe and
believe of course why not I'm not
wearing the shirt today anyway pain when
quo i hope i pronounced up properly
welcome aboard hayden here saw your
picture and thought
would you less success you're a success
Mike his name is mine hahaha it was
Mikey said Mike okay Mike okay my first
of all my name is Evan you called me
Michael typo whatever Evan listen glad
you liked the video thanks to leave in a
comment you said in the video that you
felt like I was talking to you now I'm
actually talking to you that's what's up
unbelief nation so thanks for thanks for
leaving that comment I really appreciate
it hey Pete just wanted to send the
quick shout out thank you for the
comment thank you for all the comments
man you've been a great supporter and
hate in here saw your video on which one
was it league of legends and he wanted
to say i like your jay college he likes
her Jason art I like it too it's a good
picture hey Raquel mermaid she's a
mermaid yeah mermaid junkie Kiki uh
Raquel thank you so much for the
comments I'm glad you love the outtakes
how about the personalized thank you
video Nina wants to say something no you
don't say something thank you for keep
watching please I don't know Oh cakes
are awesome i wish i had more on my
channel gotta work on not being as
polished anyway thank you gonna finish
this up watch watch some walking dead
yeah and then then we'll see anyway so
that's it party scene enjoy your weekend
good so I really however will get well
soon um I don't like it when he is sick
yeah he looks terrible when he's sick he
doesn't sleep while he doesn't really
sleep a night he was up all night last
night I think it was up to my 3am 4am
last night the night before he was at
5am so it was that good
and so I hope you get well and I love
I'll keep making him nice drinks will
tea with honey and or some lemon with
lemon with honey water so I hope you get
well soon okay thanks for watching I
believe we have been doing a lot of um
okay um what is that right yeah okay
Micha totally lost it okay I issue in
the show you then okay and so and here's
our some hi everyone my name is caleta
red i recommend that you try out Evan
Carmichael's newsletters they've helped
me to restart my business and realize my
passion which is awesome
you